my pregnancy I've been very lucky  Audrina Patridge gives birth to a  healthy baby girl well we'll have the  baby and then the wedding will probably  still be the end of the years  well one things checked off for Audrina  and fiance Corey Bohan 'he's  happily-ever-after  et has learned that the hillstar  welcomes her first child with Corey on  Friday the couple's newborn weighed in  at 8 pounds 4 ounces for me choosing a  girl name as the hardest thing Audrina  and the proud dad chose the cutest name  for their daughter  Kiera max we chatted with the first-time  mom in May about her upcoming bundle of  joy and it looks like a little Kiera  will quickly become a mini fashionista  I've already bought so many clothes oh  my gosh